l'histoire de la naissance de platon est
vraiment incroyable son père ariste on
s'apprête à des flottes je préfère
utiliser ces verbes sur youtube le père
de platon s'apprête à d'effleurer la mer
eric thione mais là le dieu apollon
intervient et n'empêche donc la mère de
platon ne perd pas sa virginité mais
elle tend quand même enceinte donc
platon né d'une mère vierge attendait ça
me rappelle quelque chose cette histoire
[Musique]
je pense que vous le savez platon et le
géant de la philosophie occidentale
bon d'accord égalité avec aristote son
plus illustre disciples platon a abordé
tous les aspects de la condition humaine
l'amour l'art l'éducation la politique
etc et il a forgé beaucoup de grandes
idées qui détermine encore la manière
dont nous les occidentaux du 21e siècle
voyons le monde mais platon c'est un
philosophe du 5e siècle avant
jésus-christ donc il y a peu de sources
fiables sur sa vie la principale source
biographique ce sont les visées doctrine
des philosophes s'illustre de diogène
laërce quand tout de même été écrite
sept siècles plus tard c'est pas l'idéal
pour rapporter les faits il ya beaucoup
de légendes concernant la vie de platon
mais vous allez voir quelles sont
révélatrices à l'égard du monde
intellectuel de la grèce antique mais
aussi du rapport de la production du
savoir avec le fonctionnement de la
société en général je vais donc partager
avec vous dise anecdote étonnante est
révélatrice sur la vie de platon ne
manquez pas les dernières ce sont mes
préférés
imaginez que warren buffett et hillary
clinton est un enfant autrement dit la
puissance financière et la puissance
politique réunie et bien la famille de
platon c'est un peu ça plate on est donc
un ultra privilégiés non seulement sa
famille est une des plus riches sinon la
plus riche d'athènes mais c'est aussi
une famille d'homme d'état du côté de la
mère la famille remontent jusqu'à selon
qui est souvent considéré comme
l'inspirateur de la démocratie à athènes
et le père a lui aussi d'illustrer
ancêtres en pratique il ya toujours
quelqu'un de la famille de platon au
gouvernement et lorsque son père meurt
platon est alors tout jeune sa mère se
remarie avec un ambassadeur réputé en
quoi cette anecdote est elle révélatrice
et bien tout d'abord plate on n'a pas
besoin de travailler donc pas étonnant
qu'ils critiquent les sophistes qui
vendent leur savoir puisque lui n'a pas
besoin d'argent pas étonnant non plus
qu'il valorise le monde intellectuel
puisque son confort matériel est assurée
le second enseignement à tirer de
l'anecdote c'est que platon est un
aristocrate qui ait un sens inné de sa
propre valeur il se sent responsable des
autres hommes et il se sent responsable
de les mettre sur le droit chemin
vous savez ce que veut dire platon ça ne
veut pas dire 152 cuit mais large des
pôles autrement dit costaud musclée en
fait platon est un surnom le vrai nom
platon et aristote laisse le même que
son grand-père il y a plus précisément
deux théories sur le sens du surnom
plateau la première dit que platon est
vraiment large des pôles ce serait son
prof de lutte qui l'aurait surnommé
platon parce qu'il était naturellement
très fort d'après la légende platon
étaient si forts qu'ils auraient
participé aux jeux olympiques il aurait
partagé sa tante avec les autres
athlètes mais sans révéler son identité
est rappelez vous qu'il est issu de la
plus puissante famille d'athènes la
seconde théorie qui me paraît moins
crédible dit que le surnom platon fait
référence à l'ampleur de son style
autrement dit le surnom signifie qu'il
est capable d'écrire de longues phrases
très travaillé très littéraire
champion de lutte un mec super baraqué
devient-il la plus immense star de la
philosophie et un platon s'est longtemps
cherché à d'abord été tentés par le
métier des armes il a fait trois
campagnes militaires et sa bravoure été
reconnue il avait aussi une fibre
littéraire et artistique
il a composé des poèmes et des tragédies
mais il a finalement renoncé à se lancer
dans la littérature mais surtout étant
donné la puissance de sa famille il
avait un destin tout tracé devenir un
des dirigeants d'athènes elle dit
lui-même qu'il a effectivement
considérer cette ambition au temps de ma
jeunesse j'ai effectivement éprouvé le
même sentiment que beaucoup d'autres
jeunes gens aussitôt que je serais
devenu mon maître n'imaginait je
m'occuperai sans plus tarder des
affaires de la cité c'est la rencontre
avec socrate qui change tout plateau
environ 20 ans et rêve d'une carrière au
théâtre quand il rencontre socrates qui
a lui 60 ans et qui est déjà célèbre à
hatem fasciné par le charisme de ce
marginal contreversé platon prend un
tournant il jette ses poèmes au feu pour
devenir un disciple de socrate
quelle est exactement la nature de la
relation entre socrate et platon
sont-ils amant aucun des deux n'en a
parlé peut-être qu'à 20 ans platon était
déjà trop vieux pour plaire à socrate il
existe deux versions concernant la vie
amoureuse de plâtre la première à la
version légendaire fait de lui un à
sexuelles avant l'heure il aurait été un
pur esprit un modèle de sagesse sans
aucun désir qui ne puisse le trouble et
la seconde version plus réaliste dit que
platon serait devenu un célibataire
endurci
après avoir était bisexuel parmi ses
conquêtes masculines on connaît le
tragédien agathon le comédien alexis le
rhétoricien phèdre et surtout dion pour
lequel il a effectué deux périlleux
voyage en sicile je vous en parle dans
une anecdote suivante parmi ses
conquêtes féminines
il y aurait la courtisane arkéa nas et
selon certains grands types la femme de
socrate après platon préféré
probablement les hommes dans le banquet
où il développe sa théorie de l'amour il
affirme que l'amour homosexuel est plus
libre que l'amour hétérosexuel
parce qu'il ne comporte pas l'enjeu de
la procréation en quoi cette anecdote
est elle révélatrice est bien le fait
que platon ne parle pas de sa propre vie
amoureuse montre qu'il veut incarner sa
théorie philosophique la théorie des
idées qui survalorise le monde
intellectuel il soumet son corps et l'an
2000 les impulsions ils ne se laissent
jamais aller une légende raconte par
exemple qu il se maîtrise est tellement
qu'on ne le vit jamais rires je connais
des gens comme ça c'est pas forcément
une légende
vous savez d'où vient la fille ofi
grecque les idées ne tombe pas du ciel
elle circule avec les hommes est donc
une des principales sources de la
philosophie grecque ce sont les échanges
intellectuels avec l'egypte l'egypte
c'était à l'époque un pays mystérieux et
fascinant la plus brillante civilisation
du monde méditerranéen les jeunes grecs
fortunés s'y rendait parce qu'il
considérait ce voyage comme partie
intégrante de leur initiation à la vie
et puis la traversée ne coûtait pas
grand chose c'était aussi une tradition
philosophique de passer en egypte
précisément dans la ville sacerdotale
d'héliopolis pour méditer sur la mort
lors de rituels spéciaux selon pythagore
hérodote et démocrite et est par exemple
passée par là platon lui cire ans après
la mort de socrate je vous rappelle la
chronologie platon rencontre secrète
vers l'âge de 20 ans et dix ans plus
tard c'est le fameux procède ce crabe
qui est condamné à boire un poison et
comme platon a peur que ce soit son tour
après socrates il quitte athènes on ne
sait pas grand chose sur ce qu'il fait
en egypte mais son séjour a probablement
eu une grande influence sur lui déjà il
vit chez les prêtres du haut clergé avec
lesquels il peut s'entretenir de
théologie et puis certains estiment que
c'est l'intérêt des intellectuels
égyptiens pour l'au delà qui a inspiré à
platon sa fameuse théorie d idée selon
laquelle la réalité matérielle obéit à
des modèles intellectuels qui sont la
réalité ultime en tout cas la ville
d'héliopolis atout pour le satisfaire
intellectuellement il y à des
bibliothèques des érudits des historiens
des théologiens incapable d'expliquer le
sens ésotérique des mythes des rites et
des noms divins l'attend est admiratif
du patrimoine culturel égyptien voici ce
qu'il écrit dans les lois alors que chez
nous rien ne demeure longtemps des
précieux souvenirs du passé l'egypte
inscrits et préserve éternellement dans
la pierre la sagesse des temps anciens
les murs des temples sont couverts
d'inscriptions et les prêtres garde
toujours sous leurs yeux cet héritage
divin il n'a pas oublié l'egypte et
l'egypte ne l'oubliera pas non plus on
raconte qu'au tour de l'an zéro des
guides touristiques entre guillemets
d'héliopolis nous traite aux voyageurs
la chambre où le g platon pendant son
séjour près du grand temple de ré
est une académie c'est une institution
dédiée à la culture et ou à
l'enseignement des lettres des sirops ou
des arts vous connaissez peut-être
l'académie française qui a été créée par
louis xiii pour encadrer l'évolution de
la langue française ou encore l'académie
de médecine française il a pour mission
d'éclairer le gouvernement en matière de
santé publique l'adjectif académique
désigne plus globalement le système
d'organisation de l'enseignement
supérieur qui prévaut tant en occident
et vous savez d'où vient le mot academy
il fait référence aux jardins d'academos
academos était un héros de l'histoire
d'athènes la tombe a acheté ce jardin en
moins 387 pourrait fonder son école qui
s'appelle donc l'académie c'est une
propriété à 1,5 km au nord ouest
d'athènes il y a entre autres un grand
jardin des sanctuaires un gymnase des
salles pour les cours et pour la vie de
la communauté et une grande bibliothèque
et qui comptera jusqu'à plusieurs
milliers de rouleaux l'at on achète
beaucoup de livres rares et chers il
donne les premières leçons au gymnase
puis les leçons plus avancé dans sa
maison au coeur du jardin il enseigne
debout en marchant sans cesse afin de
dépenser son énergie physique légendaire
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'enseignement à
la mode péripatéticienne cette manière
de faire a inspiré à un autre corps de
métiers que révèle cette anecdote que
l'école de platon qui est l'une des
premières universités connu dans
l'histoire et le modèle originel de
l'enseignement supérieur en occident est
la caractéristique essentielle de ce
modèle original c'est que l'élève
apprend sous un angle intellectuelle
abstrait et non pas par la pratique pour
le dire simplement en occident où se
forme dans les livres avec les idées
comme les disciples de platon se
formaient dans son école au début du ive
siècle avant jésus-christ une légende
raconte que les disciples de platon ce
serait crever les yeux pour se libérer
des beautés sensible et se consacrer à
la pensée pure et comment il faisait
pour lire
vous savez qui est l'élève le plus
brillant de l'académie de platon et
aristote l'autre géant intellectuelle de
l'antiquité il entre à l'académie à 17
ans et il y restera jusqu'à la mort de
platon soit pendant 20 ans je ne vous en
dit pas plus sur son passage à
l'académie parce que je veux faire une
vidéo sur la vie d'aristote anecdotes
sur laquelle je vais me concentrer dans
cette vidéo c'est le conflit entre le
maître platon et son plus illustre
disciple d'aristote d'un côté un lien
affectif les unit platon a remarqué dès
le départ qu'aristote est très
intelligent il le surnomme
l'intelligence de l'école est en fait
son principal assistant la tradition
arabe raconte que platon est tellement
attaché à aristote qu'il ne commence
jamais une leçon en son absence
seulement ils sont en conflit sur le
plan intellectuel aristote conteste la
vision du monde de son maître la fameuse
théorie des idées pour aristote le
sensible sert aussi à trouver la vérité
puisse dans philosophie politique il
n'adhère pas du tout à l'utopie imaginé
par platon dans la république à la fin
le maître aurait été vraiment déçu parce
qu'ils percevaient comme de
l'ingratitude selon certaines rumeurs
platon aurait pris peur qu'aristote
devienne son rival en le voyant écrire
autant selon d'autres rumeurs c'est
aristote qui aurait tenté un putsch à
l'académie cette anecdote est importante
parce qu'elle révèle l'origine de la
concurrence entre deux visions du monde
majeur dans l'histoire des idées
occidentales celle de platon et celle
d'aristote les penseurs des siècles et
millénaires suivant ne cesseront de
revenir à l'une ou à l'autre vision du
monde et c'est tantôt l'un tantôt
l'autre des deux géants qui prend
l'avantagé l'at on ne pouvait pas savoir
à quel point il voyait juste en
craignant que son disciple préféré ne
lui fasse de l'ombre
platon serait-il devenu un géant de la
philosophie à l'heure d'internet
peut-être pas pourquoi parce qu'il se
serait peut-être fait prendre à son
époque déjà beaucoup de gens l'accusent
de plagiaire il aurait repris les idées
mystique de pythagore sans le citer il
aurait également repris des passages de
démocrite de parménide ou encore
d'homère certaines rumeurs circulent sur
les méthodes de platon selon harris toc
scène un de ses disciples rebelles qui
sera aussi le disciple d'aristote platon
s'y prendraient de la manière suivante
ils achètent l'oeuvre intégrale d'un
auteur il la consulte puis il a détruit
par exemple en la brûlant afin de
pouvoir sont appropriés les idées ils
auraient projeté de le faire avec
l'oeuvre de démocrite mai il a
finalement renoncé parce qu'elle avait
déjà trop circuler cette anecdote révèle
que la paternité des idées étaient déjà
un enjeu à l'époque de platoche
peut-être que les autres philosophes
étaient jaloux de son prestige
intellectuel mais peut-être qu'il a bien
un volet les idées des autres est
peut-être que à l'époque comme
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas sur le
véritable créateur des idées que
rejaillit la gloire mais sur celui qui
réussit à les promouvoir dans la société
didier sur platon vous devez vous
imaginez qu'il a passé sa vie dans le
monde des idées à lire et à méditer à
écrire et bien détrompez-vous il a
essayé de mettre en pratique ses idées
il a été trois fois conseiller politique
à syracuse une colonie grecque du sud
est de la sicile il a obtenu cette
position grâce à sa célébrité mais aussi
grâce à sa relation romantique avec dion
kit est en quelque sorte le premier
ministre de l'île la première fois qu'il
se rend à syracuse 7 avant même de créer
l'académie le tyran de l'île denis
l'ancien un autocrate impitoyable et
parano est alors l'homme le plus
puissant du monde méditerranéen le
courant ne passe pas du tout avec platon
qui contrairement aux courtisans se
permettent de parler d'égal à égal avec
le tir et puis il le domine physiquement
et intellectuellement lors d'une
discussion politique platon insultes
denis l'ancien alors c'est lui qui se
venge en faisant vendre platon comme
esclaves le philosophe s'en sort grâce à
un riche ami qui le rachète qui en plus
refusera kg rembourse oui ça sert
d'avoir des amis haut placés mais
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là platon
reviendra à syracuse vingt ans plus tard
pourquoi prendre ce risque parce que
c'est désormais le fils denis lejeune et
qui gouverne et qu'il a un vrai
potentiel philosophique platon pense
donc que cette fois ci il va réussir à
mettre en pratique ses idées sur l'île
seulement les courtisans disto tyran que
la venue de platon puis en fait à aider
dion la mort de platon à prendre le
pouvoir l'at on finit donc en résidence
surveillée et contrairement à ce qu'il
imaginait le nouveau tyran n'est pas
réceptif à son influence on pourrait
croire que ces deux échecs suffisent à
platon mais jamais deux sans trois comme
on dit il se rend à syracuse une
troisième fois pour convaincre denis
lejeune de laisser revenir à dion qui
avait été chassé entre temps et encore
une fois ça se passe mal pourtant le
tyran semble vouloir se mettre
sérieusement à la philosophie il a
l'ambition d'écrire un traité mais
blaton se moque de lui il lui dit sans
détour qu'il n'a pas le niveau plateau
on finit donc de nouveau en résidence
surveillée et il faudra que son ami
architas ce le philosophe qui dirige la
cité de tarente envoie un navire pour le
ramener sain et sauf en quoi cette
anecdote est elle révélatrice on peut
l'appréhender sous divers angles mais ce
qui ressort quand même c'est l'échec de
platon à mettre en pratique ses idées
passer de la théorie à la pratique
ce n'est pas si facile surtout quand on
a passé sa vie dans la théorie et
surtout quand comme platon ou
l'intelligence e psychologique de mettre
son ego de côté pour accomplir son
projet
platon est mort à 81 ans comme bouddha
vous savez ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que platon est un homme divin parce
que neuf est un chiffre sacré et oui 81
ses neuf au carré on remarque aussi que
huit plus un égale 9 ou encore que neuf
fois de égale 18 et qu'un simple suite
égale le neuf et la valeur sacrée du
chiffre 9 se retrouve encore dans la
culture par exemple hésiode raconte
qu'il a fallu neuf jours pour séparer la
terre du ciel la guerre de troie a duré
neuf ans ou encore il y a neuf muses la
légende raconte que passionné par le
symbolisme dénombre platon aurait tout
fait pour mourir précisément à cet âge
d'autres légendes courent encore sur sa
mort il se serait éteint en écoutant un
air de flûte joué par une jeune fille ou
bien simplement dans son sommeil mais
selon d'autres versions sa faim aurait
été au contraire très pénible car il
aurait souffert jusqu'au bout d'une
maladie de peau causée par les poux ah
oui c'est pas la même histoire ce que
révèle cette anecdote c'est que platon a
été divinisé après sa mort surtout par
ses disciples probablement comme
beaucoup d'autres hommes qui ont une
importance disproportionnée dans la
culture sa gloire à exciter
l'imagination les jambes inventer des
histoires sur son compte lui ont
attribué des qualités exceptionnelles
jusqu'à faire de lui un être divin qui
est né d'une mère vierge
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plus que vous avez découvert des choses
intéressantes et même inspirante sur
platon si c'est le cas de donner un
pouce vu la vidéo et puis laisser un
commentaire pour améliorer le
référencement de la vidéo c'est pas
grand chose et puis ça m'aide vraiment
je suis romain j'étais avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous vous étiez sûr mais
l'idée de culture générale appelée vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la pensée j'ai une question à vous poser
vous croyez vraiment que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont il parle bien sûr
que non sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
grand chose
et oui il y à 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'ya pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivés les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
renan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent et à développer rapidement
et facilement leur culture générale
parce que leur rapport au savoir a
changé et une fois qu'ils les appliquent
les cinq secrets ils comprennent toutes
les références des personnes cultivées
ils savent s'exprimer avec profondeur
sur n'importe quel sujet ils brillent
par leur culture dans les conversations
c'est dans les débats et ils ont le
recul nécessaire pour faire preuve
d'esprit critique ça vous intéresse et
bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets et
je vous explique comment les appliquer
dès aujourd'hui pour vous cultivez 10
fois plus rapidement sans vous prendre
la tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit tant qu'ils ont sur celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo
croyez moi faites le et vous me
remercierez